let's talk a little bit about season
four what people can expect and look
forward to where you guys add in the
process we're two weeks from finishing
series four where we have to fly back
tonight yes to learn Benedict and I have
an enormous scene to shoot on Tuesday
morning unless you want to practice it
here or not but yeah practice it now or
you ever get out of line right there's
about 26 pages
we're doing next week it's going very
well
hmm what do you think you guys have
since the start of the show I mean I
remember when the show first someone you
know gave me a screener of it before it
even aired and instantly was well
there's gonna be everyone's new favorite
show
starting from that point all these years
later how do you think the show has
evolved and how do you keep how do you
keep the characters fresh and the
relationships intense I haven't the
faintest idea um I don't know uh well I
suppose one of the tremendous advantages
that I know is is very popular with this
crowd is that we just don't make very
many and and by just not doing it very
often we're always fresh and rested when
we make a new series something like that
what you're actually making three movies
a year though I mean that actually is a
three one movies every two years let's
not exaggerate our tiny attainment but
um in the same period it must be said
Guy Ritchie's only made two yes he get
any hassle now yeah we get all the
hassle for making quite a lot a number
I've forgotten how many will be made
every 13 soon yeah that's almost a
season yeah or as the Americans would
say half a season yeah that's it the
British are very good at they'll just do
five episodes and be like we're good and
then that's it and you don't see
anything so why do you think why how are
you guys able to continue making the
show and able to come back all these
years when it that's not doesn't seem
fun I mean from acting point of view
what you get when you first read those
scriptures the thrill hopefully the
audience gets when they when they see it
and it is the novelty it's the
reinvention of the wheel that's damn
near perfect
can indoors point of view and as we know
from the books but every time it's a
sort of placing of that it's a blessing
of what we try to achieve you know
before in previous episodes and series
and there's an evolution to all the
characters and that as an actor the real
pleasure to play and my god is there a
lot of that in this in this series a lot
of things come home to roost which is
fantastically exciting but it's sort of
chicken it's full of rooks Ravens
chickens Birds yeah they're kind of
nesting Emily care to mention
and ya know it's it's it's that really
it's it's it's the thing of what's
familiar but also what confounds
expectations right and the level of
invention and sheer Bulls enos of it I
mean it's a properly yeah I mean with no
meeting so ambitious
especially for television in the amount
of time in budget we have it's quite
extraordinary and there's also this
really there's so many great
undercurrents running under the show
there's a recurring themes about
addiction and broken relationships and
dealing with mental health how important
was that how important was that for you
guys so yes Steven there is you didn't
eat all this just knows some stories
about embodied that yeah I thought he
was solving crimes what show do you
think this is CSI Miami I'm not green
I'm sorry scooby-doo
yeah I don't know if you got know what
the trick honestly we tried we just
tried very hard over the over the last
six years to keep it evolving and that
the big thing right from the beginning
of doing 90 minute episodes film length
episodes we realize quite quickly that
we had to give them a real scale you
know and you've got to put the
characters through an emotional wringer
you can't just have story of the week
it's not really like that so as a result
you have to keep the characters
fracturing somewhere and you can't have
John Watson being constantly astonished
by Sherlock's deductions because he
would have got used to them so you have
to evolve that part of it you have to
make sure that as Doyle did that the
Sherlock Holmes at the end of the
stories is not the same man we met at
the beginning he has it has changed and
otherwise it's just not interesting I
think that's one of the
critical things about if if you're going
to do a show about a genius you can't do
a show about a genius who doesn't learn
right that doesn't make any sense he
can't be the weird scary amoral man we
met the first episode he just can't be
otherwise he's not learning and geniuses
do learn so I would imagine from the
writers point of you I mean the actors
are so brilliant that it's quite nice to
throw things at them and take them out
of their comfort zone and give you stuff
to play with I think as well isn't it
it's literally nice to throw things at
the moment yeah and toys to play with
you yeah so long as Benedict always
wears the Colt and we never changed the
code hahaha oh and quite hung up on the
code yes which I'm glad you did that
because it's going to resolve a
long-standing argument a year sue tells
me an inner inner scene of domestic
disharmony that we're going to change
the coat and I said we're not changing
the coal because I'm what you see
darling yeah yeah yeah film well there's
gonna be trouble at the mill tonight I
mean that side of win popularity new
marriage diss your wife in front of an
all H coat obsesses I'll stick up for
sue sometimes that coat needs to come
off for two reasons he wears other yeah
yeah you're darn tootin yeah that reason
to half are always might need a minute
here yeah well I wear a suit under that
coat and also sometimes it's very hot
and sometimes you could see it's hot
weather so it does come off every
nothing a bit we do we don't actually
have many we don't have many left
we don't yeah we're running we have a
lot of coach that we try every year
because every year we do try and attempt
to which is wrong and it never makes
that's what makes this I changed the
TARDIS almost every year you won't
change Sherlock's code it's still a
police box I don't know if you guys
inside the quartet I don't know yeah I
love the timeline is anyone the outside
you see in the background at the
beginning that video they had all those
notes up on the board and one of them
said Doctor Who Sherlock crossover and
then in Stephens writing over my dead
body with a bunch of exclamation
point I think you'll find that was my
Andre it's not oh they're not fair I am
not the one who lost the Doctor Who
Sherlock ha ha ha ha everybody else at
this table the blocks it right no it's
Trump uh as it is trunk did the first
part of his plan
we can't let these two get together in a
build the wall uh I love like - I like
shark I like Doctor Who I like Sherlock
I like Boosh
I want to do what Casey I like hey wait
by a pic I say or in my face I'm a hair
I like it um I didn't that's the first
time I've ever done a dog Amanda what
are you what are you most excited about
for season four the three episodes ha ha
ha
it's where it's really dark it's the
darkest that stephen and mark of written
and yes it's I'm in a doctor we when we
read them all of us the one we been we
were kind of overwhelmed by them I think
yeah cuz they were shocking and amazing
as always but they kind of if we can
pull this off then it's amazing it's a
genuine emotional rollercoaster this
series and the the learning curves are
sort of yeah they're massive um with
jokes with Jojo are there Arthur ik some
great jokes ha ha I'm Connor also quiet
yeah yeah tears
sorry drunk Sherlock oh oh gee said I
though she said jump Sherlock
very I thought you said jump Sherlock
somebody out there should do just a
specialist cosplay of drunk Sherlock
happy pretty wandering around last time
we were here there there were lots of
people in white sheets I can't see any
drunk shirt just a drunk Sherlock do you
know I mean no no is that a trunk shut
up oh yeah when he's on the stank - and
he's getting pissed he's yeah
then I go to my mind Palace yeah I
thought it was that right he's where is
this performers well you talk about
jokes but the show does strike the
perfect balance between you know you
have to manage the narrative arc but you
also have to manage the drama so how do
you how much comedy are you cutting out
of each episode to sort of keep
everything in balance we never cut jokes
both mark and I are phasma T writing oh
yeah
so we don't well you know I think one of
the hopefully a strengths of the show is
a the way we look at it is if there
isn't a major plot development if there
isn't a major moment of drama or a
fright we'll put some jokes in so
there's always quite a lot of gags in
Sherlock other meant to me they're meant
to be gags but the advantage of it being
a drama is if a gag doesn't work you can
just pretend it was a serious yeah it's
like we always say this it's like life
why I think it's such a false
distinction between comedy and drama
life is always a mixture of the two week
we talk about the daily the times you
feel you know the most under pressure to
behave the times you get hysterical and
slightly laugh about things and as in
life you're released from a terrible
dramatic situation is often humour and
that's the way it should be
shouldn't be a false distinction has to
be all po-faced are all straightforward
comedy but what's great is it in the
beginning of the series a lot a lot of
the jokes were very meta jokes about the
concept of that you were doing a
Sherlock series and they really evolved
into the relationships between the two
of you so are you are there are you
improvising it all on the set between
between you and Martin though there's
not much there's so much for
memorization but um you know this is a
this is a very beautifully tight
brilliant because he piece of music you
don't you can't it's not jazz I mean
there's jazz in the sense of how you
deliver it absolutely the rose and
there's always a
an involvement that Martin and I have
with going I'd like to try this or not
that and there's that you know but it's
my new sure and beyond that no there's
no improvisation it's about how we do it
rather than what we do
you know what we're doing is what we
signed up for which it gloriously
written scripts and it's a treat so you
don't really want to muck around with
that there emot-- there are moments I'm
trying to think in in this particular
series as well where it does get looser
for good reason you know in every regard
I mean psychologically with what
Charlotte goes through and and what
Watson goes through and what we all go
through which yeah the form of it being
that sort of competitor one saying
rabbiting on yeah there's a looseness
but you've got a very strict tempo to
obey with with with this group so I
think that's why I'm trying to saying
gosh I don't know it's fine no not at
all please don't
I mean you've to understand he's that
they all flew hail flew in to come to LA
I mean to San Diego for days I know
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
people have real conversations here my
apologies uh but uh they came here
basically just for two days and then
they're immediately going straight back
to work I mean you guys did it we did it
we did a week of night shoots and all
sorts before we got here as my hello
that's not like a cat was it good
uh-huh it's only out uh and we had it we
had a lot of pain captain manager
o'clock we had a lot of tape last week a
lot of cake a lot of cake last week you
had to hit the tree on buddy's birthday
ah happy don't do it Jojo don't don't
oh [ __ ] look what I started do you have
happy birthday mr. president what's
going on I need more sleep taking her
clothes off the longest birth area
ministry thinking about it there you go
just thank you thank you for your level
of commitment I like that this act was
like no we started and were not stopping
this train wow that was weird
ha ha ha Amanda that merit Mary's Arc
was incredible lassie and did not I mean
legitimately did not see it coming -
were you did you how does this process
work in terms of at the beginning of the
season they sit you down and go this is
what's gonna happen or do you not find
out I didn't know I was going to be an
assassin until the 3rd episode when I
read it but but I'd been told by Stephen
'mark that she had a very dark past than
a big secret and that that would be kind
of cataclysmic in the third episode
little did I know I'd have to shoot the
hero but when I read that I was with
Martin when I read it and I look to him
when I went they're going to hate me for
doing that and actually you know it but
um but it's an amazing thing to play
what an amazing character to play I
think she's you know she's I think she's
so well-rounded as it as a character and
she's tricky and she's independent and
she's sassy and she's dangerous and I
think that's really that's great for a
female actor to play I love her if the
roles were reversed would you have read
the file if the role I would if I if I'd
have would I've read the third if I had
it wouldn't know would you have read the
file about your partner's past would you
oh I would hear course absolutely yeah
I've read anything
yeah anything you fit anybody's past I'm
all over that
yeah but now I've cast yeah I think
that's really cool that he never reads
it I think that you know that's a really
good so really interesting it will just
means you know John's John's moral is
just full of cat videos yeah and picture
my puppy quite it's quite good though
you didn't know number three yeah all
those into the first absolutely and I
would have played it differently had I
knowing that that's what that that was
the out comings in Episode three I would
have played her with more of an edge and
more knowing but but the beauty of not
knowing was that you thought oh because
she's a real mild-mannered very sweet
charming character and actually she was
ruthless and I kind of liked that you
that the payoff of that was was so
intense in episode 3 yeah because at now
every character omits the characters
really could have just been all
one-dimensional I think people would
have been fine with that but now even
the fact that your character kind of
makes John address the fact that he is
addicted to drama and there's all this
PTSD and all this danger stuff that's
going on we're all flawed that's what I
love about the writing every character
in this in this series is fooled in some
way and that's so much more interesting
to watch and to play I much rather watch
a flawed character because you kind of
then you know you can't help but like
them or you you judge them that's what
you're supposed to do I think that's
what you're supposed to do you're
supposed to judge your characters my
kind like mrs. Hudson I love getting my
boy up so yeah I'm shooting she suddenly
comes out with these things you know
it's like you were married to a drug
dealer is that possible but it's just
but it's it's totally plausible because
of the writing that was its unit that's
why it's plausible how did you plan that
Stephen and Mark had you planned that
arc from the very beginning of that
season what the the Amanda when are
there
yeah the America a bit for me I mean we
deliberately made the show a bit lighter
in the first two episodes so veering it
towards comedy almost so that I mean oh
yeah and you get some a third of the way
into his last vow and it's still quite
funny yeah and then she turns round and
everything you've been told up until
that point is a dirty lie right um which
I I always like that data
some point in the day cuz that's the
truth of your life everywhere lie an
assassin so those all those moments
you're keeping an eye on all those
moments that are seemingly innocuous
moments that are very subtle that people
would never point out even just the oh
she has an amazing you know eye for
detail and she remembers things you've
already planned which scenes those are
gonna be but you don't tell her because
you don't want her to well we wanted it
to be perfect you wanted her to dis get
it there's guys to be perfect but if you
do look at it she works out the skit
caught in a moment and you see Cheryl
lock register that's odd and then get
carried away with saving John you see it
happened at the speed we like she
remembers the room number and the sign
of three all those things are there
Blizzard of words around other it says
liar amongst all the other stuff yeah he
sort of subconsciously clocking those
things but actually there's an the hood
say it who's an actor in this series who
has to sort of he has to sort of have
pretended to know something and he was
unsure about watching you when and I was
sort of trying to take him through it I
said eventually I said just pretend you
know nothing it's actually it is
actually easier when you're trying to
disguise yourself rather than playing
the result you know if you're actually
saying oh I have a secret it's actually
better not to know because then you
don't present anything right and then we
don't give anything away to the audience
there are no tells right the Victorian
special was amazing the Bominable bride
and in terms of I think I sort of
expected it to be well this is a
standalone this is a separate sort of
fun thing that we're gonna do well you
expected that because we explicitly told
you that's what it was yeah she shows
the power of lying trump Hey
you know someone's gonna make a meme of
your face Steven and it's gonna say liar
liar liar
secret Lib Dem in fairness I do say that
I'm lying
and then I lie and people get crossed
but made by the fact I told JB you're
lying then it's like trying to answer
the question is it opposite day you
can't answer that question you can't lie
all the time you've got to lie some of
the time early no one can trust you at
any point
write that down kids write that down
that's how it works but face is for
marriage as the bales in hello so what
was the decision to tie everything back
in and how did you decide to sort of
make it part of this mind Palace journey
and weave it into where the last episode
left off well it's sort of it that the
idea began is it not really as a joke
just something we've sort of batted
around be fun and we thought we'd be
fantastic that really the only two
Holmes and Watson had ever done modern
day and period with Basil Rathbone and
Nigel Bruce and we thought it'd be
brilliant it really right back to the
beginning and so but sort of treat it if
if we'd had the idea to just do Sherlock
Holmes as it usually is it would still
be that was the show we would have done
so it wasn't suddenly very sort of fusty
and slow-paced etcetera it would be
Sherlock but in that that period but if
we just had this narrow window where we
could make special where everyone's
Diaries worked and it was kind of the
only time we could tell that story was
in those five minutes before the plane
lands and then we just obviously had to
fib about it and just say it was a
standalone because it looked like we'd
gone crazy yeah but it was it was so
much fun wasn't that I mean it was a
really really odd thing is that when we
first began quite a lot of press did ask
us you know how can you do show our
codes without gas lamps and hansom cabs
and then we did some press with a
special and a couple of them said well
how can Sherlock Holmes exists in the
world without iPhone
well we've done something right there
isn't there is some precedent for it it
was great it was such fun to play I mean
it's a joy that we we managed to sort of
straddle both eras and uh yeah I'm very
happy in Victorian garb not least
because we talked about the cows loss
that doesn't appear too much and that
one but the hair it's just so much
easier having slicked back I can tell
you I spent longer in that chair getting
my head
cute what is it defusing curler what
what never suppose the ladies what is
the Sherlock hair process for cosplayers
like to know they all know it's twisted
abused yeah
I think it's got its own hashtag
somewhere yeah so a Facebook page I
notice Victorian Sherlock was a little
bit different than modern days as he
should be
yeah I mean I think you know he he
projects with some degree of accuracy
into into a past I mean you've got Molly
Hooper pretending to be a man you've got
all sorts of things that are slightly
sort of unfeasible in a real Victorian
you're I suppose though it's not
necessarily true but yeah as far as
Charlotte goes yeah he was I wanted him
to be more stiff
I want if that is possible but sort of
it you know straighter back and just a
little bit a little bit crueler and of
that era so a little bit more clips in
his dialects a little bit more sort of
crisp and polite to what era he was in
and yeah there's something slightly more
severe the edges that have been rounded
I think by Watson of the overarching
humanization of him in our version were
kind of retrograded a bit and that was
fun to play with really good fun to play
with and we also ended up with it with
an unexpected thing really in that last
scene where the credits roll and then it
suddenly goes back to Baker Street and
Sherlock says to John this is this is my
idea of what the future might be like so
which really poses the possibility that
the entire series our series is just the
fevered imaginings of a real Victorian
right so maybe the whole thing is just a
Victorian man's idea of the future don't
stuff
so I guess all further because you're
playing with time that is technically a
doctor who crossover Oh God it's
happened as close as you'll ever get but
it does seem to allow you the
possibility to jump back and forth in
future episodes you do you foresee that
ever I don't think so I think that was
the the time we could do it and and the
obvious one to do is to do it in the
original authentic Victorian gear just
to see once that way mark and I are of
course obsessed with the idea that one
day we could do the 1940's propaganda
movie worthy where they fight the Nazis
life as a raffle and Nigel Bruce but you
know if we announce that we've lost our
minds
haha you know it's not out to 2017
what's the rule --it what is the
relationship dynamic between show up and
sherlock and mycroft is a little bit
different in abominable bride so what
I'm I'm thick-headed so I sort of missed
what was what is happening with the
pudding and what is that what is that
dynamic well in the original stories
Mycroft is enormously fat and obviously
to go into the Victorian one we thought
we'd go for the for mr. creosote we
thought we talked about that for years
yeah how much fun that would be
and then this this idea of that they
actually have a bet on how long he's
going to live that's what I that's what
I'm wondering about why is what well
because the whole thing is in Sherlock's
head he's just basically having
something really cruel what we have to
all you have to imagine is that the
whole thing is actually taking place at
lightning speed in his head but along
the way he's having fun he's turning
brother into Jabba the Hutt yes he's big
making John a bit more like Nigel Bruce
etc and and having fun but but and
that's one of the ways he's just poking
there poking the finger at his brother
but also be puddings and it was meant to
be funny Chris it is funny it was funny
to be a joke and you just asked us to me
I do like the joke in public in front of
thousand people we're cute elated now
Steven I I just took it as a very
serious dramatic moment which you asked
above know the reason that I asked is
because I was trying to figure out and
now that you've explained I understand
that the relationship is so kind of
toxic that Mycroft would
uh sure his own death to win a bet with
Heather essentially that's why not so
what can we expect from my craft in
season 4 less pudding let's go ha ha ha
trimmer I'll tell you really we have
work we have a lot of fun we do this
season and a lot of things are resolved
a lot of things are raised I'm not like
everything you can't yet it's I know
it's a vessel but it's definitely it's
it's yeah it's an evolving relationship
I think you started sneaking into in
before the end of last season you really
did start peeking into the idea of it
Mycroft
really loves him and he even of course
he loves ya it's just it's like he my
goes both ways
stuff him you know he wants him on the
inside of the tent pissing out he can't
bear not literally that would be
straight you can't bear the fact that
it's that this amazingly intelligent
brother is not part of his establishment
that's that's what it is it all comes
from a place of caring it's just he
doesn't really know how to express it
that's in the first episode yeah in the
very first episode it's it's it's cold
and strange what he does but he is
worried about his brother and that's why
he asked dr. Watson to spy on him it's
not a conventional thing to do with the
family member but he's not a
conventional person he always cares yeah
recently there was a picture of Sherlock
with a dog yes
what yeah what can you tell us Allah
it's a bloodhound it was the best thing
we could do on the day with that dog was
take photographs yeah he wouldn't
[ __ ] man it wouldn't move uh we were
I mean it would use expression we were
so the blood but the stage directions
were you know there he gets dragged
around London by a voracious bloodhound
and it lit at what the owner said PA
doesn't it doesn't like concrete much
and it doesn't like crowd doesn't like
pavement pavement doesn't like people
doesn't like people we were in a market
London is not an urban dog brilliant
fantastic we found our perfect match for
an urban scene with dog you're supposed
to drag just lit I've there's one point
I was literally pulling and I just I
felt and just ended up on my back just
because he just wouldn't
move he was the lovely very affectionate
but just sat there for the whole time
and we end up getting a bit hysterical
too early we were kind of just like Ben
and I were going this we have working
very very hard to play Sherlock Holmes
in London little layer of being
self-conscious and then when you have a
bit of slathering concrete on the end of
a lead it just loses awesome like it man
prop man he was holding the lead and
Brackett shot pulling me along because
the dog was over there having a [ __ ] and
a kind of beer when you see the episode
there is actually a scene about that
that mark and I wrote standing on the
page yeah - okay but if I move you talk
about aviation that was a hastily
revised we did she had to die to account
for the fact the dog would not do what
we're supposed to do so actually it's
actually the nicest busy I think it is
this dog is just hopeless we have to
hope to account for the fight it's a
totally static tongue never work with
anyone what about the fact you know get
getting to the next season in a baby and
how does that change the dynamic
ya know how it's amazing isn't it come
shake on it
what I gotta say about specifics how do
you think Mike will be fighting you know
she's pregnant by me open the full
series I'd known forever she's pregnant
steers the look she's more pregnant than
an elephant so I've got the longest
gestation period I've ever known but um
it is an elephant is that I don't know
she
yeah I'm she the baby features the baby
features and also never worked with
babies either no no I have been compared
to the dog the baby's wearing a navy
blue shirt and god bless her she was a
beautiful baby um or he and um
projectile vomited all over me went over
the baby went over and had a cigarette
up dog up the side but we used many
babies and they were all very very sweet
and lovely but it's very difficult
trying to get you know when you're doing
a scene when you're supposed to be
carrying a baby and doing stuff and it's
the end of the day and they're tired
obviously because they're babies and
yeah it was newborn babies nothing
surprises me that somebody would give
their newborn baby over for your day
well the producer you are them I were we
need someone out there to give up if
github is it's a strange thing I'll
obviously babies on a schedule so it's
always tricky and you can't match
necessarily we're doing a filming day
with the babies routine so you have a
baby now then has a baby do you want to
know how little you're learning about
series we are actually talking about
working with children and animals
you